- [Voiceover] The graph of
function f is given below.
It has a vertical tangent at
the point three comma zero.
Three comma zero has a vertical
tangent, let me draw that.
It has a vertical
tangent right over there,
and a horizontal tangent at the point
zero comma negative three.
Zero comma negative three,
so it has a horizontal
tangent right over there,
and also has a horizontal
tangent at six comma three.
Six comma three, let me draw
the horizontal tangent, just like that.
Select all the x-values for
which f is not differentiable.
Select all that apply.
F prime, f prime, I'll
write it in short hand.
We say no f prime under
it's going to happen
under three conditions.
The first condition you could say
well we have a vertical tangent.
Vertical tangent.
Why is a vertical tangent a place where
it's hard to define our derivative?
Well, remember, our derivative is
we're really trying to find
our rate of change of y
with respect to x,
but when you have a vertical tangent,
you change your x a very small amount,
you have an infinite change in y,
either in the positive or
the negative direction.
That's one situation where
you have no derivative.
They tell us where we have
a vertical tangent in here,
where x is equal to three.
We have no ...
F is not differentiable at x equals three
because of the vertical tangent.
You might say what about
horizontal tangents?
No, horizontal tangents
are completely fine.
Horizontal tangents are
places where the derivative
is equal to zero.
F prime of six is equal to zero.
F prime of zero is equal to zero.
What are other scenarios?
Well another scenario
where you're not gonna have
a defined derivative is where
the graph is not continuous.
Not continuous.
We see right over here at
x equals negative three,
our graph is not continuous.
X equals negative three
it's not continuous.
Those are thee only places
where f is not differentiable
that they're giving us options on.
We don't know what the graph is doing
to the left or the right.
These there I guess would
be interesting cases.
They haven't given us those choices here.
We already said, at x equals
0, the derivative is zero.
It's defined.
It's differentiable there.
At x equals six, the derivative is zero.
We have a flat tangent.
Once again it's defined there as well.
Let's do another one of these.
Actually, I didn't include, I think that
this takes care of this problem,
but there's a third scenario
in which we have, I'll
call it a sharp turn.
A sharp turn.
This isn't the most mathy
definition right over here,
but it's easy to recognize.
A sharp turn is something like that,
or like, well no, that
doesn't look too sharp,
or like this.
The reason why where you
have these sharp bends
or sharp turns as opposed to something
that looks more smooth like that.
The reason why we're not
differentiable there is
as we approach this point,
as we approach this
point from either side,
we have different slopes.
Notice our slope is
positive right over here,
as x increases, y is increasing,
While the slope is negative here.
As you're trying to find
the limit of our slope
as we approach this point,
it's not going to exist
because it's different
on the left hand side
and the right hand side.
That's why the sharp turns, I
don't see any sharp turns here
so it doesn't apply to this example.
Let's do one more examples.
Actually this one does
have some sharp turns.
This could be interesting.
The graph of function f is
given to the left right here.
It has a vertical asymptote
at x equals negative three,
we see that,
and horizontal asymptotes
at y equals zero.
This end of the curve as x
approaches negative infinity
it looks like y is approaching zero.
It has another horizontal
asymptote at y equals four.
As x approaches infinity, it looks like
our graph is trending down
to y is equal to four.
Select the x values for which
f is not differentiable.
First of all, we could think
about vertical tangents.
Doesn't seem to have
any vertical tangents.
Then we could think about
where we are not continuous.
Well, we're definitely not continuous
where we have this vertical
asymptote right over here.
We're not continuous at
x equals negative three.
We're also not continuous
at x is equal to one.
Then the last situation where
we are not going to be differentiable
is where we have a sharp turn,
or you could kind of view it
as a sharp point, on our graph.
I see a sharp point right over there.
Notice as we approach
from the left hand side,
the slope looks like a
constant, I don't know,
it's like a positive three halves,
while as we go to the right side of that
it looks like our slope turns negative.
If you were to try to find
the limit of the slope
as we approach from either side,
which is essentially
what you're trying to do
when you try to find the derivative,
well it's not going to be defined
because it's different from either side.
F is also not differentiable
at the x value
that gives us that little
sharp point right over there.
If you were to graph the derivative,
which we will do in future videos,
you will see that the derivative is not
continuous at that point.
Let me mark that off.
Then we can check x equals zero.
X equals zero's completely cool.
We're at a point that our tangent line
is definitely not vertical.
We're definitely continuous there.
We definitely do not have
a sharp point or edge.
We're completely cool at x equals zero.